[Music]
the kovit 19 pandemic has transformed
all our lives lockdowns have forced us
to change
how we socialize how we shop
how we work
but as vaccination rates rise parts of
the world are opening up
it's a wonderful feeling to go back to a
festival like this again
but which changes are temporary and
what's transformed for good
to answer that question the economist
has crunched data to create a
groundbreaking new
index the amazing thing about this
pandemic compared with all previous
pandemics is the amount of data we have
the results show that the world is never
going to be the same
again
this is not the first time a pandemic
has changed the world
historically crises revolutionized
societies
fueling technological advances and
kick-starting
social change in the 14th century the
black death played europe
back then lockdowns were brutal infected
people
were locked up in confined spaces to die
and there were different approaches to
social distancing
[Music]
about a third of europe's population
died from the plague
but from the devastation came innovation
having fewer workers encouraged the
development of new technologies
labour was much more scarce and so that
some historians think
led to the development of labor-saving
devices such as the printing press
because you know you don't want to be
paying scribes to copy things out you'd
rather have a machine that could do it
more cheaply
some theories even suggest the black
death made europeans more adventurous
piling onto a ship seemed less risky
when so many people were dying at home
in the following decades dozens of
expeditions explored new lands
fast forward a few centuries and the flu
pandemic of 1918
looked surprisingly similar to what
we've experienced recently
schools theaters and businesses were
shuttered
there were mask mandates and anti-mask
protests
[Music]
up to 100 million people died from the
flu
that's more than triple the number that
died in another crisis
you might be more familiar with the
first world war
the flu hit as the war was ending and
both
ignited change if you look at the first
world war
the men went to the front and so women
had to work in factories
and took on a lot of jobs that they'd
previously not been able to do
so it had a big impact on you know how
people saw the equality of the sexes and
whether it was appropriate for women to
work and so forth
and after the pandemic ended businesses
were inspired
to take more risks from 1919
the number of startups in america boomed
we can notice these historical changes
in hindsight
today it's possible to quantify change
as it's happening
the amazing thing about this pandemic
compared with all previous pandemics is
the amount of data we have i mean the
fact that we're all walking around with
these
computers in our pocket you've just got
that sensor network that's sort of
inherently there
we've got an unprecedented amount of
data and in fact you know almost more
than we can
we can deal with an ideal situation for
a data journalist like james
he's crunched the data to create an
index for normality
so the index that i've made basically
looks at 50 countries at
behavior in in those 50 countries around
the world
and the idea behind it is to track how
things are
have changed during the pandemic and how
behaviour might persist
beyond the pandemic make his index
james analyzed eight different
indicators of behavior
which can be split into three categories
the first is transport
flight data public transport usage and
traffic congestion
the next is leisure use sports
attendance
box office takings and time spent
outside the home
last how business is being done office
occupancy
and retail football that gave james
thousands of data
points to analyze
based on all this data we arrive at a
baseline for what global normality looks
like
where 100 reflects normality zero
means that there's no activity at all
and a value of over 100
means that activities occur in greater
levels and occurred before the pandemic
this line is our overall global
normality index
it reflects in aggregate how behaviors
changed over the past 18 months around
the world
we looked at 50 countries in total and
every country looks a little bit
different
for example here is the chart for
britain you can see that activity fell
dramatically last spring
as restrictions came in activity rose
once more through the summer before
falling as the second wave occurred
and since then activity has risen as the
vaccination program has gotten underway
to see how the index looks in your
country click on the link
data are great at giving a sense of what
the world looks like now
but the index can't predict the future
tom the economist's resident future
gazer is trying to
the world before the pandemic is gone
we're not going back to it the big
question
is to what extent are things going to
snap back we're not going to snap back
all the way it's clear that
people aren't going to go on doing all
the things they've been doing in the
pandemic but nor are they going to go
back to the way things were before
so the answer's going to be somewhere in
the middle and exactly where it is in
the middle is going to vary
by country by activity by industry by
household
and so that's what makes it so
unpredictable
so we're entering into a hybrid world
where people do things online as well as
off
this has been a pretty big change for
most people
but especially for italians specifically
how they shop one of my favorite
examples concerns e-commerce in italy so
italians were not big shoppers online
before the pandemic they like to buy
things in person it's a very
social experience to go shopping in
italy during the pandemic
it was a different story restrictions
here were tough
and in the first half of 2020 more than
2 million italians tried online shopping
for the first time ever today despite
restrictions being lifted
the amount of people shopping in person
in italy is still below pre-pandemic
levels
there are all these stories of italian
granny sort of getting addicted to
amazon and realizing they can buy things
with a few clicks
and then buying all sorts of stuff
that's an example of how you know when
you discover
a new way of doing things during the
pandemic you're likely to want to go on
doing it
amazon is betting on the fact that they
will keep doing it
it's hiring thousands of new employees
in italy
but our new online lifestyle goes way
beyond shopping
[Music]
possibly one of the biggest long-term
changes from the pandemic is going to be
more people working from home
our index shows that office occupancy is
rising
but it probably won't ever rise to
pre-pandemic levels
companies will probably let people work
from home or the office
i quite like working from home one of
the things i like the most is not having
to put on a shirt
and a suit to go to the office i can
just put on a shirt when i need to
right now for example i'm wearing shorts
and i've got sandals on
tom is very modern wearing his shorts
for work
but it's not just about new trends we've
also rediscovered some old ones
there's one case where rather than being
accelerated into the future by the
pandemic we've gone back into the past
and that's with drive-ins or
drive-throughs the number of drive-in
cinemas across
britain has exploded from three to forty
during the pandemic
and it's not just the uk walmart car
parks
um many of which may have been drive-ins
in the first place got repurposed as
drive-ins during 2020.
there was a nightclub in germany that
did a sort of drive-in night
so we've had this sort of return to the
drive-through back to the 1950s vibe
even as in other respects we're being
accelerated into the 2030s
but we will only know the full impact of
the pandemic once it's over
and that could be a long way off until
you've got really really widespread
coverage with vaccines that are really
really good
at handling these variants then we're
not going to see the back of this
pandemic
but using data to chart the changes
we're all living through
helps us make sense of it all it's been
really good to see people's rise in
interest
in numbers it's the first time that i've
seen charts on the
headline 10 o'clock news on the bbc or
itv we're sort of adding to that flood
of data with this normality tracker but
you know it is a tracker that's showing
how things are getting better rather
than a thing that lets you obsess on how
things are getting worse
i'm james ranchim i'm a data journalist
the economist to see the latest data of
our global normality index
click on the link thanks for watching
and don't forget to subscribe